BUT GREAT THINGS WHEN THEY TALK
THERE IS A SHOT ON THE NET.
>> Ajay: FIRST OFFICIAL SHOT
MORE DIFFICULT FOR YOUR
GOALTENDER.
NOW WE HAVE ICING THE OTHER
WAY, FOR DALLAS TO GET STARTED
ON THEIR OFFENSIVE ZOGOOD
SKATERS.THE
CORNER.
AND  IT MAY
HAVE BEEN AL PLAY.
JUST SO GOOD FOR THIS TEAM.
ONE OF THEMCK IN, AND A BREAK
AWAY FROM THE RAFFL.
AND YAMAMOTO HAS OF IT.
WE ARE ENDING THE FIRST PERIOD,
BEST OF THAT ONE.
BUT McDAVID HAS A LOT MORE
FRONT OF THE PENALTY BOX.
ACROSS THE LINE, JACOB ROBINSON
LOOK AT THIS.
THIS IS THE DROP
CODY CECI BETWEEN I
AM EXCITED TO BE A PART OF
THAT.
>> TO GET IT OPEN
THERE.
JUST COMING A COUPLE OF
PLAYS THEY HAVETO THE
RIGHT PART OF YOUR SCREEN, HE
WANTED THAT PUCK SO BADLY, BUT
THEY JUST COULD NOT CORRAL, AND
GOING FOR THE BACK END! IT JUST
ANDD HE GETS BACK -- THERE HE I
ON THE RIGHT SIDE
AND A SECOND OPPORTUNITY AND
HEADS TO PHOENIX TO TAKE ON THE
COYOTES TOMORROW NIGHT.A SCORE!
BEAUTIFUL DEFLECTION.
THE DEFENSEMEN TO JUMP IN. THAT
AND I THINK THAT MIGHT HAVE
MISSED HIGH.